[Musique]
bonsoir
il y a quelqu'un
[Musique]
ce que je veux que vous fassiez c'est
que vous vous releviez
waouh mince je suis désolé que vous ayez
vu ça je ne sais pas qui est cette
personne
il y a eu un mail envoyé ton compte la
nuit dernière quoi le pire c'est qu'il y
a une photo de toi ou tu es à moitié nu
vous réalisez que ça a été envoyé à tout
le monde je vous explique quelqu'un a
piraté mon compte est-ce que vous ne
pourriez pas jeter un coup d'œil à mon
ordinateur et voir d'où ça vient je ne
peux pas on n'a pas d'unité de
cybercriminalité au commissariat
la ferme ta gueule
[Musique]
si tu en parles à quelqu'un je veux que
tu saches de rien avant que l'avant ne
sera rien comparé à la presse
soyez imprévisible
[Musique]